la reacción de ti el saler es muy
importante y se utiliza mucho en
síntesis para obtener moléculas
complicadas del lado izquierdo tenemos
alguien que tiene dos dobles enlaces y
del lado derecho tenemos al bien o filo
y como filo significa amor el bien o
filo ama a alguien en general el bien o
filo tiene al menos un grupo aceptar de
electrones que retira densidad
electrónica de este doble enlace así que
el bien o filo es relativamente pobre en
electrones mientras que el día no es
rico en electrones y podemos pensar en
que los electrones fluyen del 10 al 10 y
lo a eso se le conoce como reacción peri
cíclica que es una reacción en un solo
paso y ocurre mediante un estado de
transición cíclico entonces si pensamos
en un poco de densidad electrónica
fluyendo desde el día al día no filo
podemos empezar moviendo estos
electrones hacia acá para formar un
enlace entre estos dos carbonos también
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá
para formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y finalmente estos electrones
se mueven hacia abajo así que tenemos 6
electrones moviéndose al mismo tiempo y
así obtenemos el producto de la derecha
que es un anillo de ciclo ex xenón
resaltemos los electrones estos
electrones en rojo formaron este enlace
estos electrones py en el 10 nov y lo
formaron este enlace y finalmente los
electrones en rosa del día no se
movieron para formar el doble enlace y
todo ocurre al mismo tiempo
y yo dibujé a los electrones moviéndose
en esta dirección pero no hay problema
si dibujan el movimiento hacia la
derecha
lo importante es mover los 6 electrones
para obtener el producto practiquemos un
poco con algunas reacciones sencillas de
ti el saldo por ahora no nos
preocuparemos por la stereo química
entonces primero hay que identificar al
día no y al bien o filo del lado
izquierdo tenemos al bien y del lado
derecho tenemos al bien o filo ahora si
pensamos en la densidad de electrónica
fluyendo del 10 al día no filo podemos
mover estos electrones hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos también podemos mover estos
electrones para formar un enlace entre
estos dos y estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar otro enlace
entonces si dibujamos nuestro producto
hemos formado un ciclo externo y unido a
este carbono tenemos un aldehído
resaltemos los electrones estos
electrones en rojo se movieron para
formar este enlace estos electrones py
en azul se movieron para formar este
enlace y finalmente los electrones py en
color rosa se movieron hacia acá para
formar este doble enlace así que todos
estos 6 electrones se movieron al mismo
tiempo en esta reacción de un solo paso
veamos el siguiente problema del lado
izquierdo tenemos al lleno y del lado
derecho tenemos al bien o filo entonces
este es un 10 pero observen que tiene
una conformación diferente arriba
tenemos un día no en la conformación es
csic donde
s se refiere a que este enlace es simple
o sigma pero aquí abajo tenemos la
conformación ese trance porque observen
que los dobles enlaces se encuentran
trans respecto al enlace simple así que
primero necesitamos rotar este enlace
para pasar de la conformación trans a la
conformación cis ahora tenemos al día no
en la conformación s cis y necesitamos
que se encuentre en esta conformación
para que pueda ocurrir la reacción de ti
el sal de entonces ya estamos listos
para la reacción así que estos
electrones se mueven hacia acá para
formar un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos y observen que esta vez tenemos
un triple enlace aquí arriba sólo
teníamos un doble enlace pero los
alpinos también pueden actuar como 10 no
filos entonces
estos electrones se mueven hacia acá
formando un enlace entre estos dos
carbonos finalmente estos electrones se
mueven hacia acá dibujemos nuestro
producto esta vez tenemos dos dobles
enlaces en el anillo y después tenemos
este grupo unido a este carbón que
corresponde a este carbón vamos a
dibujarlo aquí tenemos un este y lo
mismo ocurre aquí abajo muy bien
resaltemos los electrones estos
electrones en rojo se movieron hacia acá
para formar este enlace estos electrones
pie en el alc y no se movieron hacia acá
para formar este enlace y estos
electrones en rosa se movieron aquí este
es nuestro producto muy bien hagamos
otro aquí tenemos otra reacción de ti el
sal del
el lado izquierdo tenemos al bien y del
lado derecho tenemos al hielo filo y ya
podemos mover nuestros electrones porque
el lleno se encuentra en la conformación
cis entonces estos electrones se mueven
hacia acá para formar un enlace aquí al
mismo tiempo que estos electrones se
mueven para formar un enlace acá y
también movemos estos electrones
dibujemos el producto
aquí tenemos nuestro anillo y unido a
este carbono tenemos otro anillo
dibujemos los grupos carbón y lo este es
nuestro producto resaltemos los
electrones los electrones en rojo se
movieron aquí los electrones py en azul
se movieron aquí y los electrones en
rosas se movieron acá entonces los 6
electrones se movieron al
tiempo pero qué pasa si les dan el
producto y les piden el bien y el bien o
filo bueno hagamos un ejemplo sobre eso
supongamos que nos dan esta molécula y
nos piden encontrar la combinación de
bien y de bien o phil bueno hay que
pensar en mover los electrones en
reversa empecemos con estos electrones
si los movemos en sentido contrario
después estos electrones en azul los
movemos hacia acá y finalmente estos
electrones en rojo los movemos hacia acá
dibujemos el lleno y el día no filo del
lado izquierdo en el día no tenemos dos
dobles enlaces que se ven así y del lado
derecho el yen o filo es un anillo con
dos grupos carbón y lo resaltamos los
electrones los electrones en rosa se
movieron aquí
electrones en azul se movieron acá y los
electrones en rojo se movieron acá así
que para revisar que estamos bien en un
problema como éste simplemente hay que
tomar el día y el día no filo y
comprobar que obtenemos el producto de
la derecha así que al pensar en la
reacción inversa de di el saler podemos
obtener los reactivos iniciales